Jeff passed him back here in the Rich
Eisen show how you doing Jeff just
coming in soft these days nothing uh
nothing nothing light here so walk me
through what you know about the major
league baseball I guess
netting policy is in the stadium Jeff
well two years ago Major League Baseball
recommended that every team out there
extend the netting to the inside edge of
the dugouts and that was a perfectly
wonderful half measure to take something
that honestly compared to what has been
done around the world in Japan for well
over a decade now has been done in minor
league parks is is embarrassingly soft
for I believe teams that first year
extended the netting all the way to the
far end of the dugout which protects a
whole lot more people from the screaming
foul balls that fly and stands like the
one yesterday that hurt the child at
Yankee Stadium like ones that have
injured thousands literally thousands of
people every year going back for four
decades now and so the the fact that
this policy does not include at least a
mandate to have netting all the way to
the end of the dugout if not all the way
down line is just it's it's
reprehensible and it's morally wrong and
that to me is the great issue here that
Major League Baseball is more concerned
about everything other than the safety
of its patrons well what is the
everything then what why otherwise their
mortgage they are more concerned about
restaurants that are going to be on the
concourse is they're more concerned
about the amenities that are in the
ballpark they're more concerned about
the between innings games that I mean
when I say everything rich I mean
literally everything and the reason
behind this is something called the
baseball rule it's it's essentially a
doctrine that courts have upheld
throughout the years that fans are
liable for what happen
to them at a baseball game and and while
I understand the I the notion behind
that that you there's an assumption of
risk when you walk into a stadium at the
same time if there is something that the
teams can do to mitigate if not
completely erased that risk from the
people who are paying good money to go
and watch these games I don't understand
what's preventing them from doing that
that to me is the big question here what
do you have to lose it's the same
question that hockey asks after Britney
Cecil died and this was this is a wild
girl I think it was 2002 when a puck
flew into the stands and and killed a
child and it's almost like baseball is
waiting for that moment to happen in
order to spur it to action to do what
should have been done because you ask
any hockey fan these days you get used
to the netting it's just it becomes part
of the experience you may not like it
but you come to terms with it and that's
where I think most baseball fans are
these days you come to terms with this
and the trade-off for the additional
safety that's in place to me is such a
such a significantly more valuable thing
than whatever you might lose from having
a net there Jeff Passan of Yahoo Sports
join him here and I think you hit this
in your column I said this earlier in
the show but for any fan out there that
baseball thinks exists that says you
know what I've got these these seats my
my my season seats have been on the
first base line or my family my family
passing it down for all these years or
they like sitting first third base line
that I I don't want a netting I don't
want that visual impediment that those
fans if given an opportunity to sit two
or three rows behind home plate and the
best seats in the house which have
always been covered by netting would
they turn that down because I have to
see through netting I mean if none of
that makes sense to me Jeff of course
now it mean you you put it you put it
well the seats that are considered most
desirable not for everybody but you know
we're all going to have our own
preferences but the seats that are
considered most desirable
a baseball stadium are covered by next
and and you know what I've sat behind
home plate before I don't see the
netting your your eyes adjust so so that
it literally is like you're watching the
game without anything in front of you
the human brain is a wonderful thing and
it turns out the things that you don't
want to focus on and if you want to
focus on the net if you want to focus on
the game you will focus on the game of
the players in the ball in everything
that comes with a baseball game the one
argument to me in favor of not putting
up netting is that it takes away from
the experience of catching a foul ball
you know what though balls can be tossed
into stands by players balls can be put
through special areas in the netting if
if teams want to do that you can make
the experience if not as good and
certainly in that same neighborhood and
and the ability for parents to take
their children down into that area and
get closer to the field and and really
grow to love baseball
the way that I think you especially can
when you can smell the grass and you get
that close to the game and see the speed
and the excitement to me the trade-off
there is enormous and anybody who wants
a ball you know I go to Dick's and buy
lunch yeah I'm with you
Jeff Passan if you're always sports here
but it's not as if no major league
baseball teams haven't expanded the
netting there if there's about ten that
have are there any metrics from the fan
experience there that could be passed
along to the other twenty teams that
appear to be less inclined to basically
say fans have instead of a boo or peep
about it let's put it this way if there
was enough of an outcry or a backlash
against the netting they would have been
taken down in some of these places I
don't think this is like a Pandora's box
for once you open it you can't close it
again and shockingly rich none of those
ten teams have taken the netting gap
anecdotally and this is just based on
where there so I understand the sample
of people is certainly is biased but the
vast majority who III either talked with
or who sent me messages last night said
I fit behind the netting and I don't
notice the difference at all there were
a couple people who were still saying I
don't I don't like the idea of it
one guy said I've had season tickets if
they put netting up I'm not gonna watch
baseball and he's so full of crap I mean
come on are you really telling me that
if you love a game and love the
experience you're going to let something
get in the way of it when that something
is so negligible of course you're not
and you know what teams that kowtow to
these tough guys saying I'm going to
cancel my fine cancel your season
tickets somebody else will get good
seats and appreciate them more than you
do
and they deserve that more than you do
anyway well I mean in and you know phone
lines are lit on on this show today
about this subject Jeff and that's kind
of you know typical in a way that you
know if if we're on this show sitting
here saying who's gonna win the NFC West
NFC East who do you think is the best
team in the AFC and I give an opinion
phone lines are gonna like about my team
this team that seemed the only way the
phone lines have light for for baseball
when we're talking about pennant races
that are heated up or anything like that
is when something like this happens I'm
being honest with you this is my this is
my experience my metric or when or when
ode or clocks Batista or chase utley
slides late into second base in a
playoff game like that that RIT are you
saying regular-season baseball is
irrelevant
no I'm not saying that I'm a die-hard as
it come you know you are saying that
though and you're right you're a hundred
percent right this is like the
existential crisis I have between April
and October how do i how do I write
about something that's interesting when
people don't care about a sport except
for what their team is doing no you're
totally right but these I mean the fact
that that baseball's most exciting
moments come during brawls and and when
children are getting injured
it does not indicate a great
of health for the sport and and trust me
that's something that I think Major
League Baseball teams are grappling with
right now and the fact that they're not
using this as something to say we care
about you fans we want your experience
to be better I think shows a deep deep
ignorance on on behalf of the 20 teams
that haven't done something to this
point so then in the last minute I have
with you of Jeff Passan of Yahoo who do
you think is gonna win the World Series
who's in it who wins it based on what
we're sitting here on the back half of
September here what do you think boy I
you know I I really hate predictions
because I suck at them but if we won't
don't worry but we all do we all do
I really like the Washington Nationals
in a month ago before the Dodgers just
started folding like that I wouldn't
have said this but Scherzer Strasburg
Gio Gonzalez at the top of rotation is
great their bullpen has been solidified
with the boos Mike Rizzo made if Bryce
Harper comes back and is even 80% price
Harper
I think the Nationals are going to be a
really hard team to beat in the American
League I think it's going to be in the
ins Astros and it's going to be a whale
of a series I'm not picking against the
Indians right now though there's a ton
of firepower there their bullpen is
fantastic and if I'm picking a World
Series champ today maybe it's the fact
that I grew up in Cleveland maybe it's
the fact that I want to see a team
that's taken 69 years to do this but I
think the Indians right now the
favorites Jeff great chat let's chat
again soon thanks for calling pleasures
mine rich thanks for having men that's
you gotta it's Jeff Passan of Yahoo
Sports very passionate as you can hear
at Jeff Passan PA SS and on Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about